welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid after my last video on things to
fear I thought I'd bring you some
balanced fear not this is my top 5 list
of things not to fear because science
number one rogue black holes this is a
black hole in orbit around the galactic
center but not in the Galactic plane
that means it might pass by stars or
through solar systems as its orbit takes
it through the Galactic plane it's scary
because we can't actually see black
holes that's why we call them black we
can only see stuff fall into one so we'd
never see it coming if it was headed for
our solar system the odds of it
happening are extremely low as the
galaxies form 12 to 13 billion years ago
most of the matter zipped into the
Galactic plane before ever forming star
sized objects like black holes there are
some stars outside the plane in what's
called the halo but we always see them
in huge dense clumps called globular
clusters there aren't any stars out
there just zipping around all by
themselves the earth happens to be
located in a very stable very calm area
of the galaxy if it wasn't then we
wouldn't exist number two the Sun
exploding yes the Sun will eventually
expand into a red giant engulfing the
earth however this won't happened for at
least four billion years or so how can
you possibly know that science we are
very familiar with the Sun yes we still
have a lot to learn but that's mostly in
the details we've got the major stuff
down measurements of the Earth's orbit
tells us the mass of the Sun so we know
how much stuff there is in it and based
on the light it puts out we know how
fast the fusion process is happening so
we can very easily measure how much fuel
that has left it's a pretty simple
calculation in the grand scheme of
things sleep well knowing the Sun will
be there when you wake up every morning
three lightning strikes here in the US
we average about 25 to 30 deaths by
lightning per year that might seem like
a big number but you have to compare it
to the total population of the country
314 million people that's one one
hundred thousandth of a percent of the
u.s. population furthermore there is an
average of about 23 million lightning
strikes in the US per year
I don't think the Lightning likes the
humans very much for brain aneurisms
ever notice how in movies and TV shows
there are always people dying of these
and it's the most horrific thing ever
the aneurism itself is just a bulging
artery in your brain one fiftieth of the
u.s. population has one of these at any
given moment and they often pass without
incident it only becomes a problem if it
ruptures
but this occurs in only 1/100 of a
percent of the u.s. population each year
it can cause some brain damage but most
victims of a ruptured aneurysm will
survive don't believe everything you see
on television they like to play with
your heartstrings number 5 vaccines
why of course I want controversial for
number 5 there are a few arguments
against vaccines let's go through them
shall we
I heard that vaccines cause autism boy
if vaccines cause autism we'd have a lot
more autistic people walking around
frankly if autism was caused by any one
thing we'd have it eliminated by now to
all the parents of autistic children who
just screamed at me through their
screens I'm sorry there may well be
something in some vaccines that is one
in a hundred contributing factors to
autism but it is not enough to warrant
not vaccinating children I don't want to
give my baby diseases
WTF people it's better they get a dead
form of the virus now then one that
could make them dead later and when they
do contract something later and they
probably will they can spread it to
others and possibly cause an outbreak
kids are dirty and germy they haven't
had time to learn proper hygiene you
have a responsibility to adequately
prepare their immune systems for things
frankly I know plenty of adults who
haven't learned proper hygiene through
vaccines we have eradicated smallpox
from the entire planet go humans
hopefully I've alleviated some of your
fears through science or at least I've
freed you up to fear something else what
fears have you conquered in your life
let us know in the comments I will
become your new fear and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
you